have you ever wanted to know what it's
like to freeze dry one of those Crystal
candies do they get crunchier well we
don't know we're gonna find out too so
we're gonna put some of those on the
tray and then also too we're gonna
freeze during some other fun stuff so we
have this gummy controller we also have
these Hello Kitty marshels that are
filled with deliciousness Juicy Drops
including a pen and then we have this
brand new slime with our squeeze that
we're gonna put on the tray it is so
good it's so much better than the actual
slime licker and then of course Pop
Rocks we're gonna leave the freezer for
about 24 Hours come back tomorrow to see
it all turned out
the results were wild look at how big
the marshmallows got the crystal candy
got even harder and it was actually
really hard to chew through too the
large Gummy controller most of it didn't
finish but it was still really good the
Slime liquor squeeze turned into this
deliciously smelled so good blue
raspberry powder and then of course we
play with marshmallows but yeah here's
some more crushing ASMR